- I want to dress as Morticia
Addams and drink this.
(upbeat spooky music)
- We're here to drink goth lattes.
- It's a latte that's
black, like our souls.
I'm assuming what makes it
black is activated charcoal.
- I'm so confused about
this charcoal thing.
Somebody explain it to me.
- It's the counter to the rainbow trend.
Everyone's done with rainbows,
and they want things black as their soul.
- Got it.
(upbeat spooky music)
- [Woman Offstage] You can open your eyes.
(gasps)
- [Both] Ooh!
- That's gorgeous.
- It's so pretty.
- It is so pretty.
- Whoa!
- It's almost like gray.
- It smells like a latte.
It looks like death.
This is unsettling for some reason
I can't quite explain.
- I really like it.
- It's just coffee but
it looks fucking awesome.
- It's like I'm gonna
start drinking demon souls.
- [Both] Cheers.
- The texture is slightly different.
There's a little bit more graininess.
- I mean it's really good.
Tablespoon of charcoal's in this?
- That seems like a lot.
(laughing)
So I'm going to.
- Yeah.
- I like insist on holding it like this
even though the handle is
so small and difficult,
because I don't want to
cover the awesomeness
of this black liquid.
- When we first got these I
thought this was a blue glass,
but it's just clear,
And that's the color that the latte was.
- Yeah it's amazing.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- We are in a sort of
darker era of history now.
- The darkest timeline,
and we now have a coffee to go with it.
- The thing I like about goth
is just the visual aesthetic.
Goth food looks cool,
doesn't really affect the
taste that much to me,
and I'm all for looking
as cool as I possibly can.
Just gotta hold on to that.
- I know people make fun
of uh all the trends of
like adding food coloring
essentially to everyday foods
and making them cool, but I would say
there's nothing wrong with
playing with your food
and having a good time and
making things visually fun.
Go, make your food art.
Drink your goth lattes.
- Yeah enjoy your food.
Enjoy how it looks, too.
- Enjoy your life.
There should be a dark,
like a goth unicorn latte.
- Goth unicorn
- [Both] Ooh!
- That would be cool.
- It would like, it
would have like sprinkles
and like a horn or something
- But they're black.
- [Both] Yeah
- Okay.